et y'a bon jour commence pas cette
nouvelle manifestation et quel est le
programme de cette mobilisation
alors le programme de cette mobilisation
à l'appel du collectif sos retraité de
partir de la place de la république où
nous nous trouvons en ce moment pour
passer par de la bastille pardon pour
passer à la place de la république pour
atteindre opéra et bien aujourd'hui à 18
profession se sont donnés rendez-vous
lors les avocats bien sûr mais également
les infirmiers les kinés le secteur
aérien pilotes teams les orthophonistes
en tout 18
profession regrouper contre cette
réforme des retraites qui menacent leur
pension et qui à leur promet de cotiser
plus un par exemple pour les avocats ça
passerait de 14 à 18% à 28% de
cotisations ce qui est énorme et puis
des baisses de pensions prévus toujours
pour les avocats 2000 1400 aujourd'hui
pour certains à 1000
alors aujourd'hui les robes noires se
sont déplacés en nombre
il ya des barreaux de toute la france
valenciennes lille cambrai le barreau de
paris nantes poitiers ils sont vraiment
déterminés on peut l'entendre au bruit
derrière moi il ya beaucoup de sifflets
de tambours de musique et ça ne s'arrête
pas en fait je pense qu'ils ont envie de
faire le maximum de bruit pour contrer
cette réforme de retraites aujourd'hui
avec dix huit professions qui sont
entrés dans une grève glissante depuis
le 3 janvier
merci beaucoup katia pique nique un je
le rappelle en direct des rues de paris
pour suivre cette nouvelle mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites